der riesige Hype um Graphen flach seit
Jahren einfach nicht ab und das ist
natürlich völlig berechtigt aber habt
ihr schon mal von Graffin gehört dieses
Material hat theoretisch Eigenschaften
von denen Graphen nur träumen kann wie
zum Beispiel die Kontrollierbarkeit der
Leitfähigkeit noch bessere Stabilität
und eine tunebare Gitterstruktur lange
hat es nur theoretisch auf dem Papier
existiert doch nun geschah der
Durchbruch und es gelangt tatsächlich
endlich einer Forschungsgruppe der
University of Colorado bolder dieses
Material herzustellen ob es hält was es
verspricht genau darum geht es jetzt
[Musik]
egal ob wir Graphen oder Graphen
verstehen wollen beides beginnt mit
Kohlenstoff Kohlenstoff das Element hat
vier Außenelektronen und deshalb gerne
vier Verbindungen zum Beispiel mit
anderen Kohlenstoffatomen und es ist
einfach der perfekte Legostein wenn man
so will weil man damit 1D 2D und 3D
bauen und immer mehrere Bindungen
eingehen kann wenn unser Kohlenstoffatom
zum Beispiel mit vier anderen
Kohlenstoffatomen eine Verbindung
eingeht dann haben wir Diamant eines der
härtesten Materialien der Welt jedoch
kann sich das Kohlenstoffatom auch nur
mit drei anderen Atomen verbinden dabei
entsteht bei einer der Verbindungen eine
sogenannte Doppelbindung und das ist
dann Graphem das bienenwabenförmige
Material ist seit Jahren in aller Munde
es ist fast schwerelos leitet Strom und
Wärme extrem gut ist flexibler als ein
Gummiband undurchlässig für Gase und zu
allem Überfluss auch noch stärker als
Stahl diese Stabilität hängt mit der
Bindung zwischen den Atomen zusammen
stellen wir uns mal vor wir dann eine
Person an der Hand und drehen uns dann
kann schon passieren dass da die Hände
auseinandergleiten weil unsere
Verbindung einfach nicht stark genug
waren also halten wir uns mit beiden
Händen aneinander fest weil das stabiler
ist und genau so können wir uns eine
Doppelbindung bei Kohlenstoffatomen
vorstellen hätten wir Menschen nun drei
Arme naja dann wäre es am stabilsten
sich mit allen dreien aneinander
festzuhalten ich glaube ihr versteht das
System wenn Ihr noch mehr über Graphen
wissen wollt dann könnte ich übrigens
dieses Video hier von uns anschauen nun
fragt man sich natürlich wenn eine
Dreifachbindung stärker ist als eine
Doppelbindung wieso stellen wir dann
kein Material nur mit Dreifachbindungen
her und da seid ihr schon auf einer ganz
heißen Spur denn diesen Gedanken hatten
auch viele Forscher und Forscherinnen
bei so einer Dreifachbindung erhält man
nämlich das Material kabin das sieht
aber einfach nur aus wie ein Kohlenstoff
Seil es ist eindimensional und dadurch
in der Handhabung nicht so simpel aber
was soll unser Kohlenstoffatom auch
anderes machen andere
Bindungsmöglichkeiten gibt es leider
nicht
wollen wir nun aber weiterhin ein
zweidimensionales Material haben also
unser Graphen 2.0 dann gibt es folgende
Möglichkeit man Part Graphen mit Kabinen
und deren Baby wenn man so will nennt
man dann ganz kreativ Graffin ein
zweidimensionales Material das die
positiven Eigenschaften der beiden
Materialien in sich vereint
bei einer hey dieses Video hier wird
übrigens von Google unterstützt und die
haben uns gefragt wo wir im Alltag
klimafreundliche Entscheidungen treffen
nun zum Beispiel kochen wir hier im Team
mittags immer gerne alle zusammen und
das tatsächlich jetzt schon seit einigen
Jahren komplett vegetarisch außerdem
fahren wir so oft es geht mit der Bahn
zu unseren Drehs und haben auch nur
einen Firmenwagen und der ist elektrisch
selbst kleine alltagsentscheidungen
können eine große Auswirkung haben wenn
sie von Millionen Menschen getroffen
werden deswegen hat Google auch gerade
neue Features eingeführt wusstet ihr zum
Beispiel dass ihr bei Google Maps jetzt
auch kraftstoffsparende Routen angezeigt
bekommt die haben weniger Steigungen
weniger Verkehr und er konstante
Geschwindigkeiten wenn ihr also mal das
Auto nehmen müsst und nicht mit den
Öffentlichen fahren könnt dann könnt ihr
mit diesem Feature Sprit und damit CO2
und Geld sparen oder ihr fahrt wie wir
schon E-Auto dann könnt ihr das in den
Einstellungen bei Google Maps angeben
und die kraftstoffsparenden Routen
werden anders berechnet denn ein E-Auto
hat andere optimale Routen als ein
Verbrenner danke an Google für die
Unterstützung bei diesem Video hier und
jetzt zurück zu Graffin
graphin ist zum einen stabiler als
Graphen und hat zum anderen auch weitere
wichtige Vorteile bei der elektrischen
Leitfähigkeit dafür müssen wir uns ganz
kurz die neue Gitterstruktur im
Vergleich zu Graffin anschauen durch
eine unterschiedliche Gitterstruktur
verändern sich auch die Atomorbitale die
zeigen die Aufenthaltswahrscheinlichkeit
der Elektronen an die für die
elektrische Leitfähigkeit relevant sind
erstmal Graphen hier bilden sich
sogenannte p-Orbitale an jedem Atom man
kann sich das vielleicht für einen
löchrigen Swimmingpool vorstellen indem
die Elektronen ihre Bahnen ziehen
dadurch dass sie nicht so stark an den
Atomkern gebunden sind ist die
elektrische Leitfähigkeit in diesem
Swimmingpool sehr hoch und Sie können
ihn ohne große Schwierigkeiten
durchqueren technisch ausgedrückt leitet
Graffin also Strom extrem gut aber die
größte Stärke von Graphen ist
gleichzeitig eine potenzielle Schwäche
bei Graphen fließt der Strom schnell in
mehrere Richtungen so dass es unmöglich
ist den Stromfluss nur in eine Richtung
zu steuern und hier kommt graphin ins
Spiel und man sieht direkt dass es einen
Unterschied macht welchen Weg das
Elektron im Gitter nimmt um von einem
elektronenkreisverkehr zum nächsten zu
kommen durch diese neue Anordnung lässt
sich mit Graffin gezielter Strom leiten
und zwar mit der gleichen
Geschwindigkeit wie in Graphen dadurch
das Graphit einfach nicht so ein
symmetrisches Gitter wie Graphen hat
gibt es eine energetisch bevorzugte
Richtung für den Stromfluss und deswegen
ist es für viele elektronische
Anwendungen theoretisch besser geeignet
als Graphem beispielsweise könnte man
Graffin sehr gut bei Transistoren
einsetzen die brauchen wir vor allem in
Computern beim bisherigen Einsatz von
Graphen muss man es leider aufwendig
gezielt an bestimmten gitterstellen
zerstören um diese Eigenschaften zu
erlangen das kann man sich nun mit
graphiden sparen aber Graphit kann
vielleicht sogar noch mehr neben
Anwendungen bei Transistoren und
Sensoren gibt es auch erst Überlegungen
für salzwasseraufbereitung aus salzigem
Meerwasser sauberes Süßwasser gewinnen
das könnte eine Lösung für den
weltweiten süßwassermangel sein durch
die neue Gitterstruktur bei Graffin
entstehen Löchern zwischen den
Kohlenstoffatomen diese Löcher sind groß
genug damit Wassermoleküle hindurch
kommen können aber sie sind nicht groß
genug für Salzmoleküle in der Theorie
kann graphin 100% der Salze im Wasser
abfangen gleichzeitig ist die
Wasserdurchlässigkeit ungefähr doppelt
so groß wie die der bisher verwendeten
Technologien was ziemlich krass ist okay
graphin hat also echt interessante
Eigenschaften die uns in vielen
Bereichen wieder Informationstechnik
Energie speichern und auch
Wasserstoffspeicherung helfen werden
aber natürlich nicht falsch verstehen
das heißt nicht das Graphen damit aufs
absteckleisten gestellt wird zumindest
momentan ist das auf jeden Fall
einfacher herzustellen als graphiten und
durch seine kompaktere Struktur bietet
es ebenso wichtige Vorteile wie
beispielsweise seine
materialflexibilität die bei Graffin
deiner nicht gegeben sind der erste
Schritt in Richtung Anwendung wurde nun
durch die Herstellung von Raffin
definitiv gemacht jedoch müssen wir uns
auf jeden Fall auch noch etwas gedulden
bis graphin wirklich kommerziell genutzt
werden kann sobald es die ersten großen
Innovationen mit Graffin oder anderen
neuen kohlenstoffgeweben geben wird
erfahrt ihr das natürlich hier bei uns
als allererstes bis dahin bleibt
neugierig euer Cedric wie du Nummer 209
101 Tag 1 Graffin ist zum einen stabiler
als Graphen und zum anderen hat Pascal
inzwischen genug kommen sie auch
nächstes Mal wieder